hitler was convicted and served nine
months in prison where he spent his time
riding mineconf
oh hello can you hear me
yeah good evening everyone just a bit of
housekeeping um please silence all of
your cell phones we don't want them to
ring while david king
is talking uh also
we have c-span is filming us
so if later at the question and answer
portion if you'd please go to the mic
on this side
so that you know
you can be heard
also after the
event during the sign before the signing
if you would please take your chairs
and lean them against something solid
just you know help us
make this
store orderly looking again
uh
okay so to the event um
at a time when there is a growing sense
of unease among sensible people because
of the rise of fascism
it is now important for us to look
towards the past and analyze the
conditions
that made fascism possible
so naturally we turn to our historians
as our guides into the murky and
labyrinthine
realm of the past
one such historian david king
is here with us today he is a fulbright
scholar who earned his master's degree
from cambridge
and a professor who once taught you
european history at the university of
kentucky and you're a new york times
best-selling writer
he has written several acclaimed books
of history such as vienna 1814 and death
in the city of light
here he is here with us today to read
from his new book the trial of adolf
hitler the beer hall putsch and the rise
of nazi germany
kirkus reviews calls david's new work an
astute work of scholarship and vivid
narrative
a meticulously researched deeply
instructive work
with great relevance for our current era
of right-wing resurgence
and joseph cannon writer of the book the
good shepherd
says that david's new book is a
courtroom drama both farcical and
ominous
an absorbing detailed account of a
crucial but often overlooked chapter in
hitler's rise
george santayana once said that those
who cannot remember the past are
condemned to repeat it
please let us welcome who
with this writing and research makes us
remember david king
wow thank you very much thank you for
that warm welcome thank you for coming
out here today and being here can
everyone hear me okay
i
i'm used to roaming when i talk so i'm
not i don't know i'll try to stand
behind here and kind of be chained to
the podium and see how that goes i refer
to rome but i want to make sure everyone
can hear me but thank you very much for
for coming out today it's a pleasure for
me to be here
and we were coming up
a publisher is going to book the tickets
and i was like no no no
we'll make it a road trip and so i
brought my family very special guests
over here
and my my muses and um
so we walked down to make sure we would
not be late no more uh unforeseen
uh experiences but what what a wonderful
bookstore here i mean it's just an honor
for me to be here
imagine for a moment
catching adolf hitler alive and hauling
him into the courtroom and putting him
on trial for his crimes or at least part
of his crimes this is sometimes a dream
sometimes a premise you know a fantasy
or for a novel many novels have been
written about this um
well
it actually happened
in february 26 1924
nine years before hitler came to power
hitler entered the courtroom in munich
to stand trial for high treason
this is because a few months ago in
november 1923
hitler had stormed into a crowded beer
hall fired a pistol into the air and
declared that the national revolution
has begun but the national revolution
did not begin instead hitler
eventually was arrested after hiding out
and uh and
actually staying in the attic of an
american german-american woman
who left an incredible uh you know
unpublished handwritten memoir of hitler
her guest over the weekend but this was
the so-called beer hall putch and it had
failed hitler had become a laughing
stock
in many circles and his career seemed to
be over
even the great newspapers like the
frankfurter zeitung
wrote an obituary on the nazi party the
new york times
announced hitler's career being over
and it probably should have been over
well what happened
it may not be what you think it
certainly wasn't what i thought when i
started
researching this and i started
researching this book
five years ago
five years full time
i just finished my previous book the
death in the city of light which takes
place in nazi occupied paris and there
was a serial killer on the loose and he
was chopping people up and he got filthy
rich from his murders true story i mean
he's a
gruesome
account and so ironically i was looking
for something a little less dark
and ended up ended up here
but i went down as always i'll go ahead
down my list of history topics what i
want to work on next and these lists
just seem to get longer every book i
write they get longer rather than
shorter
and i was chasing down you know one wild
eye idea after the next now one rabbit
hole after the next um you know one wild
goose chase after the next
i mean i went through these i'm probably
very amusing and exasperating for my
wife and everyone i would um
corner and tell them about my latest
idea i went through them like like a
crazy person
and all the while the topic was there in
front of me
one of my favorite lectures i used to
give back when i used to teach at the
university of kentucky
was on the beer hall putch and i'd bring
in you know my millions of german marks
that my mother-in-law uh she's a swedish
mother-in-law that she had gotten when
she lived in germany you know bringing
these millions of marks and pass them
around because that was really what i
thought of for the book i thought you
know this was always something that
really interested me
in not just as an economic phenomenon
but a social cultural psychological
ordeal you know with the exchange rate
being 4.2 marks to a dollar
on the eve of world war one by december
1918 it was eight to one
and then it goes down ten to one fifteen
to one twenty to one hundred one five
hundred to one a thousand to one a
million to one millions to one you know
eventually goes down to hundreds of
millions and bottoms out into the
trillions you know the low trillions to
one so i mean your life savings
you know won't even buy you know a cup
of coffee and in the in the old sense i
mean red cabbage in munich at this time
cost 10 billion marks in the market
so this nightmare
that's that's what i originally thought
of because there hadn't been a book on
the push at that time in about 30 years
and i thought the story had a lot going
for it was a city at a turning point you
had the sweeping action in the drama the
melodrama the hyperinflation nightmare
the apocalypse of capitalism it seemed
at the time and you have these
conspirators plotting revolution
you had a cast of characters young adolf
hitler yet airmen going rudolph has
heinrich himmler alfred rosenberg and
many many others
many future leaders of the third reich
all young all in munich at this time
you've what six people have been in
nuremberg war crimes trial already here
and as you say if you want to learn
about somebody one way
look at them when they're young
and you could use the this push i
thought to understand munich at the time
because i was also long struck by this
shift of music i mean what a
sophisticated cultured city a city of
painters and poets and romantics and
dreamers bohemians how does it become a
haven for the far right
if it could happen to munich who is safe
that was how i went into it i was always
i i i but as i got into this
i thought well i've been i couldn't
believe i'd been a book in 30 years but
then as i started researching it i was
struck by something else
and all the wonderful books you know the
vast scholarship on adolf hitler the
classic biographies landmark studies
there had never been a book on the trial
a full book on the trial in the english
language
i couldn't believe that because one of
the first books i've ever read in hitler
i mean beckham was a teenager alan
bullock he's an oxford professor at st
catharines college you know he's at
nuremberg tri trial expert and you know
expert on through cities i thought i was
a classist for a long time ago and so i
liked it for the
acidities and tacitus but he said if you
know he was always most impressed with
hitler during the trial uh some of his
um his political skills were never more
revealed than during the trial he said
but yet there's never been a book i
couldn't believe it i thought this was
astonishing i thought there must be
something wrong maybe the source is
maybe there are any sources and that's
always a deal that's been a deal breaker
for me many times i had my heart broken
many times i found this wonderful story
and there's just not enough sources not
enough good credible sources because if
you're writing history
and
you know if you don't have sources and
you can't make it up i mean all the
dialogue even accounts for the weather
it's all from the source and if there
are sources i mean i've never done
historical fiction so i would be i would
be lost so i
but when i started looking at the
sources i found that with this trial
it was a gold mine
the trial transcript itself is almost 3
000 pages the complete unabridged copy
of the original german transcript
verbatim dialogue hour after hour of
hitler on the stand fencing with his
opponents or just attacking them as he
tries and does score with the audience
the munich police files
thousands and thousands of pages here
it was incredible i mean they had linked
the interviews and interrogations with
many of the ringleaders many people
minor anybody they could catch alfred
rosenberg rum
heinrich himmler heinrich hoffman many
many other people
they searched the nazi party offices and
confiscated you know a list of the
inventories of everything they took so
you know you could picture i mean the
paintings on the wall
um you know i found the pictures and
they found a picture of these uh you
know these as they quote two gypsies
that they couldn't figure out who it
belonged to
the bicycles um
it was almost like a mental pompei you
know this is like the nazi party was it
gets banned and they you know all that
was there um the damage to the beer hall
interviewing the beer hall manager i
mean it was it was incredible um
yeah the papers of the lawyers
at the trial both prosecution and
defense
and one of my favorites here was this
unpublished memoir of the deputy
prosecutor with nice summary views of
hitler after he interviewed him for his
first time um
and he was not impressed
among other things in his files you had
the tickets the tickets to the trial you
had to have these admission passes to
get in because uh they were very much
afraid of uh riots and attacks and the
you know thugs and hooligans coming in
and
trying to free hitler so he had these
special passes his his was there
uh memoirs um
oh of course there's hate mail hate mail
was in an archive also in munich the
hate mail to the prosecutor including
some from the united states
how dare the prosecutor you know
go after somebody a patriot like hitler
um
memoirs
besides the obvious published ones there
were unpublished memoirs like ulrich
graf hitler's bodyguard
there was in munich and it was just you
know he gets shot up
jumping in front of hitler maybe saved
his life
the valet of the guy who's marching arm
and arm with hitler at the pooch
who do dies uh but his valet wrote a
published memoir i mean it wasn't just
on and on and on um
unpublished handwritten notes of the
woman who hit hitler in her attic
describing how they're showing up
how hitler's blaming people like
ludendorff and for the failure
there's a plan to get hitler away before
the police come because they're going to
be coming eventually including she gets
her plumber
who's a
one of an ardent nazi that she knows and
he has a motorcycle so the the plan was
to kind of put him on the you know the
sidecar and motorcycle and throw some
blankets and tarp over him and speared
him away but hitler was not didn't go
for that
other writings
the letters of airmongering's wife um
karen
who's swedish she brought home to her
family in sweden
and this is always fun because uh
i mean so we're just fine in fact that
swedish sometimes hurts my german
because when i was in germany i have to
struggle we have to concentrate a
hundred percent or swedish will come out
because in my brain they're almost too
close as far as speaking reading is one
thing but speaking you know the swedish
is a lot more informal language so you
can
not care if we can insult somebody with
it too informal to do that you know you
may not want to do in german but but
there wasn't there are letters in
swedish back describing this time of the
push describing goring's ordeal
and job offers that growing had
in the meantime
or how uh you know the a jewish family
uh a kind jewish family uh saved goring
uh or at least attended to his wounds
after the after the push after he got
shot
well um
of course the nazi files the hopped
archive which was captured by the us
army
had all these interviews with storm
troopers
u.s army captured this and um
and then i'll brought it back to germany
but this was available on microfilm so i
had these things for years and i have
copies of these at home they're fabulous
reads um
it's also the reports of the us vice
council
who claimed to live across from hitler
and he did later on but he did not do it
at this time
um
files from landsberg
you may have followed this and this when
i was researching a previous book
they discovered these files
in nuremberg are nuremberg flea market
they've probably been stolen from uh or
at least disappeared they've not they
end up in a flea market
the director of lionsburg prison
apartment had been
robbed and somehow they ended up years
later at a flea market and this is
everybody visited him in prison
um
you know this is the spread carter which
is that you go in you get a stamp how
long you get to stay and
so
uh
so that was that was a wonderful
surprise um so
i had a i got in my topic uh the trial
opened february 26 1924 in the former
dining hall of the military academy
because they couldn't have a room big
enough
and secure enough
other than this
is a massive undertaking
nothing like in germany for years
several newspapers said
there are about a dozen about defense
lawyers a team of judges 24 days of
proceedings reporters came from all over
germany and europe france switzerland
britain
scandinavia elsewhere to cover this
sensational trial which became
scandalous from the get-go
and hitler would take this stand chief
defender speak hour after hour
uh with his very guttural voice um he's
not quite shrieking
as we're used to it seems by
in the again loss of press the press
covered this in great detail and you
know describing how he would speak and
how he would move and um and you know
sometimes if you hear hitler if you ever
heard him when he's not screaming i mean
he's it's this is unsettling and somehow
he's not even dismissed as the screaming
lunatic but in what he you know the
speaking just lowering his voice with
his gun at all it's pretty
uh pretty frightening
that's hitler here up close across the
room hitler and all his narcissism all
his megalomania
his mesmerizing demagoguery one
journalist in the audience a future
pulitzer prize winner uh h.r
knickerbocker thought hitler was quote
probably the greatest spellbinder of all
time
and then he said late his memoir
actually used probably number two
the one person who was better speaker
than hitler
was leon trotsky his opinion
so we see hitler and all his talent
all his incompetence
hitler under pressure acting
in the spotlight and he's getting a a
you know growing following
we see ruthless selectivity as he
struggles with the truth which he you
know truth did not want to stand in the
way of a good line you know he has a
famous boast of uh turning his this
party
probably all seven members in the back
room into a movement of millions the
party was always a movement for hitler
and of course he says it's at the trial
he says it might cough and it's not true
they do not have uh
millions because the police files when
they grade the office um
they tried to get the files they didn't
get the file but one of the nazi uh
workers in the office wrote in a letter
which is in the hop dark
you know they had like 55
787 members
so not exactly a movement of millions
so hitler would take the crowd into a
world of alternative facts
all the while he exploited the lower
instincts of the crowd appealing to the
you might say the least intelligent
person in the room this is not theater
the judge would say many times
hitler spoke not to
the courtroom but thanks to uh the
presiding judge
who had his own reasons that was another
big surprise for me
hitler the judge is always presented as
this ardent nationalist and he was well
he had something else going on
and
i don't want to spoil it i'll tell you
afterwards but uh he has something else
going on
and
because of that hitler speaking to the
biggest audience he'd ever have it's not
just people in a beer hall in munich
but a courtroom and
thanks to the reporters and the judges
all of germany and the world
so this will be his first major
autobiography free minecoff
and he uses it to spread a mythology
about himself
and this was an incredible moment in
history in many ways the authorities had
hitler in their hand he faced high
treason
he did not deny it in fact he bragged
about it
the law was on the side of the
prosecutors
you know lengthy prison sentence and
then deportation after all hitler was
not german he's austrian and the law
said you know
he should be deported as a foreigner
this was the chance to remove him and
instead we see day by day glowing
reviews in some circles particularly in
the far right he becomes less and less
mocked the beginning of the trial you
can still see reporters misspelling it
hitler with two t's or like something
like in new zealand
when he's when hitler's bragging about
his military uh background you know it's
like von hitler or lieutenant colonel
hitler i mean not not with irony we're
thinking of him like that and these
mistakes would be less and less common
as the trial goes on his background will
be less bungled and less mocked
as it goes on
so by the end hitler is far more
powerful than ever before he's not this
buffoon who botched the push
he's becoming more of a national figure
than he had been before and some people
a national hero and national martyr
so he turns the tables on his accusers
say i'm not the traitor
it's the government
but you know the traitors in the
government that's the enemy
and the court will send him off to
landsberg prison will he'll as you know
write
semi-autobiographical alternative
historical manifesto mineconf
using the trial to some some extent as a
basis for some of some of it and rebuild
his party which had been banned and has
fallen into squabbling factions
and seemed like hitler
on the way to the dustbin of history
so hitler relieved this period of the
push and the trial and the prison a much
more dangerous enemy to the german
republic in the world
so the trial of hitler isn't sure it's
not just sensational in a
terrific or terrible scandal as many
reporters noted at the time it's a
catastrophe
he was not locked up as the law required
nor was he deported
he would be released on parole
as it turns out
you know
hitler was even on parole
when he went to the beer hall when he
committed the crime at the beer hall he
was already on parole
so he gets out
and you'll find new more effective ways
than a beer hall push to undermine the
constitution civil liberties and the
fragile democracy
thank you
[Applause]
does anybody have any questions
let me ask the question uh first
question uh
i'm from the caribbean
but i
grew up in the netherlands
and when i went to the heart to the
netherlands there was still
a tremendous rage against germany at
that point in time i mean things have
changed so i could remember that and i i
grew up with around people taking care
of me who were involved in some
resistance type of thing
so this leads to a few questions the
first question is
i don't know if you have it in your book
but a book has been published
10 or 15 years ago now
about
the problem with the german legal system
that the german legal system and one of
my backgrounds is a lawyer i started on
the netherlands but but the importance
is that
uh the premise of the book is that the
german legal system from very much the
late 1800s
1890s beginning of the 1900s
had been on the mind
with a profound sense of anti-semitism
and that um
it basically was
there to be had by by the coming nazis
by the nazis that's the first question
the second question is how hitler to a
large extent right as he develops his
power
uses a lot of the modeling that was
going on in the united states
in germany right eugenism and
i mean the violence against you know the
minorities et cetera et cetera so um
what do you have to say about that i
mean do you see that developing in his
eye as he's as he develops this you know
his political program right and
ultimately the last one would be
you know um he never won
the majority of the popular vote in
germany right he got rid of the
parliament
but he got enough of the popular vote
right
to in against the situation that germany
was facing to be able to
uh to simply to gain power so how do you
see all of these uh issues playing out
and leading you know to the figure of
hitler
and maybe the last question do you see
it do you see do you see do you see a
potential
do you see a potential danger
of not exactly hitler but somebody like
it like coming to power in the west
again thank you
yeah thank you
oh yeah um
i think
the anti-semitism
definitely
i think also one of the problems that
you had with the weimar system is
when they were making a republic
a lot of the judges who enforced the
laws
were still monarchists and were not
removed from power like the judge in
this case nighthard
was very much
an old-style monarchist
and
never really came to terms with this
republic idea which was
imposed from the out this was germany's
first republic
um the weimar republic now fragile and
ultimately going to be wrecked from
within even as hitler comes to pout
comes to power as you said never never
having the uh
popular vote
but i i think that was one thing that we
see here um there was a statistician
writing in the 1920s that went in and
reviewed
the many cases in the german legal
system this is like you know 1919 up to
about 1922
and out of the you know 350 plus
right wing
suspects
the so vast majority of these are going
to be let off with basically a slap of
the wrist
and
if you compare it to the
suspects on the left on the other hand
which were far fewer
had
you know
i have a lot of this in the book you can
see where they uh they would have um
much harsher sentences you know 10 to 12
years sentences are a lot longer than in
the far right so
like there's a
carl dietrich bronco for example german
historian talked about how
this the legal system is like this
wellspring for the rise of the of the
third reich because of the because of
the legal system being you know with the
um there's some wonderful books you can
read i could
refer you to if you know more about
you know how it develops from say the
age of bismarck i'm more done with more
volume which i kept a lot of that but
you know from the weimar as it turns in
and when hitler comes in you know one
thing he does when he's tried here is
the people's the people's court is the
institution in munich
at the time and hitler will
recreate you know the people's court
and the big change he'll do is he won't
let him talk he won't let defend us talk
near as much as he was allowed to do
when nighthawk let him just talk and
talk and talk in the system he will
under he'll she will change that
so i i think you've raised a lot of good
points about just the the anti-semitism
and the
you know the structural challenges
that they would have
um
well i have one and then a follow-up to
what you just said
i'm a lawyer
among other things
and what was it about the law
that
that gave hitler such an advantage i
mean we've had other people here who've
talked about
the third reich and how important it was
that lawyers cooperated with it
like the guy who ran poland for instance
was an important lawyer then and there
was something about the legal system
that made
the authoritarianism or the
totalitarianism
of it
uh easier
uh that they came to work for hitler and
it all sort of sort of fit in with the
kind of law that they had
what was it about the law i think
i think i think there are couple things
i think what one thing that
you have is like
the way it worked at the time uh a
defendant would be allowed
to talk
um
question witnesses
at will pretty much and hitler will do
that
and the judge
will be criticized by a lot of people
like behind the scenes for not taking
more control
of this of the situation and allowing
hitler to speak on and on and on and
he's like well he i wanted to make sure
they could
you know present their case to the
people
and so knightheart who's who's the judge
at this time is working with that and
they also have this tradition for like
these closed sessions
that they can go into in fact there's
even a
an attempt to make the entire trial held
behind closed doors
um and a lot of the trial will be held
in closed doors and in the early
transcripts um like i bought something
was 1924 they don't have access to these
closed doors but you know they've come
out and like the germans published in
the 90s in a wonderful addition
we we end and then the full transcript
has the has the closed sessions and so
that's another strategic ploy that
they'll be working with you'll maybe try
to make your case and they move to
closed door session
um
and they have a lot to hide
because of uh
the versailles treaty for one thing uh a
lot of the you know germany almost
seemed like an unguarded arms
dump
i mean the you know the law the france
you know they
they had these very strict
rules on
what what you could have after the war
you know not an army larger than a
hundred thousand people you know no
limit to everything
and they're hiding these and like that
like the guns like they're they're held
at the time of the push in a church
their head and they for kind of like a
fraternity a dueling society they have
them there
and
they don't want this out
um you know because the french are
following this i mean the french papers
were wonderful sources for this because
they were very interested in this
because they expected this all along and
they have all these like fighting
societies or patriotic societies
like the storm troopers would be a big
benefit when they closed down some of
these fighting societies who were
helping the army
because they were able to
help shield these weapons so that's
another
thing that they have to kind of
guard they don't want that to come out
and they also don't want
the involvement of the bavarian
government to get out
so they have a lot of things at the time
that the like the judge
is trying to
protect protect exactly
yes
okay thank you thank you
yeah
the way i understand it is that uh the
featured speaker at the beer hall
was to be ludendorff it wasn't hitler
hitler woods
claimed he was like the drummer for
ludendorff what
you may have a different view on this
but
my question really is
how did how did hitler displace
ludendorff
as the sort of leader of a revoncious
germany
yes thank you yeah these everybody has
great questions
um
the speaker the night of the beer hall
was actually going to be
the general state
commissioner gustaf von
um who was like uh almost he was
appointed because germany's an emergency
situation you know what the currency was
going crazy this is right at the height
of that so they appointed this guy and
gave him almost
gave him strong executive powers
leaning towards on the dictatorial side
so he was going to speak in fact in the
book we have a guy found an invitation
to the beer hall on that night when he
was going to speak uh november 8 1923
when gustav von karr is going to speak
and ludendorff he'd actually seen car
that afternoon
but he was he hitler will show up
because hitler will send um
somebody out three or four people out to
go pick him up and bring him in and
ludendorff will always deny you know
ludendorff you know one of the famous
generals of world war one the
you know the far right he's seen his you
know one of the best generals ever and
another people see him as you know
basically causing germany to lose the
war by some of his reckless campaigns
um
he he comes in he pretends not to be
associated with in fact in some hit
major hitler biographers you'll still
see him described as coming in in his um
in his uniform which he did not do you
can see all people describing that and
he wore civilian clothes because he
wants to
i think um you know he has he has a he
has a cover in case it all goes wrong i
mean he has a tendency of doing these
another like you know the cat puts he
happens to be walking downtown right
when they have this put you know he has
he seems to cover his bases very well
but
but you're right that's there's another
um
transition here because ludendorff was
like an idol to the far right i mean to
the left i can't stand it and because
you know if it's i mean just for a lot
of reasons um
but the right he's seen as a you know
more of a national hero at the beginning
but as the trial goes on i mean
ludendorff does not come out very well
at all compared to hitler ludendorff's
the style and you see the press reports
you see you know ludendorff is the
ludendorff trial at first
and then with time
except for the you know the nazi paper
they have they'd like to send hitler's
name first but um
and a few others but you start to see
hitler replacing him
because hitler will will take the
responsibility he's like yeah i did this
you know i i take all responsibility and
lewd glasses oh no no you know north
they say he's blaming everybody except
himself
as one newspaper said he did just like
he did when he wrote his books you know
he blamed everybody except himself um
and so he
doesn't come across i mean like there's
this wonderful french communist paper
he's just having a ball with ludendorff
because you know the brave general who
just uh who was scared to be convicted
so he he does not come out well at all
in fact loondorf will run for office
right after this and it's just i mean
it's a disaster i mean the
people vote for him is like
less than three percent
if i could with a follow-up
um
i i'm also under the impression that
ludendorff at one time had a nervous
breakdown toward the
just before the armistice was signed
and that he advised the kaiser
to
end the war
did
hitler use that to undermine ludendorff
ah
well yeah i think yeah hitler you could
definitely see ludendorff with his with
his breakdown
and he's um
and hitler well sometimes he's
interested in watching him at the trial
because he will
i mean loud norfolk is getting hammered
um
in the press because of his statements
they're like does this seem like a
general is this does this guy seem to
have the brain of a general he seems
more like a a cadet
and someone said no no he doesn't seem
like a cadet he seems he seems like an
ass
i mean they're talking about his
it's just grotesque some of the things
he goes on the stand he's blaming
germans problems
on germany what's wrong with germany
it's the catholics
it's the marxists and the jews
and you know somebody say well okay
who's
that covers a lot of people um
and
and hitler will walk this balance line
and there's this great uh german
socialist paper who had a great uh
comment in my opinion because it says
how ludendorff is going on there he's
like a loose can he's just talking and
talking in fact a lot of people think
you'd get to take the stand because they
didn't know what he'd say who says stuff
just like that
and hitler
instead of alienating people he was able
to um
he was distancing himself
from ludendorff he said at one point
goes well i'm a catholic i'm a catholic
uh
hitler says and he's
um i mean he makes no mistake saying
he's anti-semite i mean he makes that
very clear at the trial um he you know
and marks us but
he is uniting the far right in a way
where ludendorff is dividing him i mean
one person looked at ludendorff and so
if you look at the far right you can see
one part
is you know like the the racists the
nietzsche's
like they they actually use nietzsche
and
several other thinkers
they say they're anti-jewish and some
extent anti-catholic anti-christian and
then you have this other side of the um
the far right and hitler's bringing him
he was trying to unite them whereas
ludendorff is really appealing to a
small part of the far right and so he's
kind of
you can kind of watch him go down as
hitler's kind of you know going up up
during the trial with all the attention
some historians say that the
japanese political assassination of
by the military and their exoneration at
their trial started the second world war
did you see any parallels between those
trials in japan and this trial
uh i i would
hesitate to speak about that i don't
know a whole lot about the japanese
trial um
i've read some on the nuremberg and i
was looking at some trials but i don't
really know a lot about like the you
know
i have a couple books at home on that
trial
and but i don't i wouldn't know enough
about it to say about the japanese trial
um
but uh
yeah um a couple of things uh
if the worldwide depression hadn't
occurred
uh do you think that
uh the nazis could have taken power
and also uh
uh this is this is hard to judge but
don't you think that anti-semitism
in germany
was far less than that in
france
russia and eastern europe
see yeah these are good i mean you know
in the 19th century and pre-hitler
well um
the first one i
i it's always hard to say what
could have happened if it didn't i mean
to be almost it's very hard to imagine
hitler becoming power without the
depression
i mean without it you'd be getting an
alternative history
since it didn't happen so it's hard to
say since it didn't happen
but i mean without the depression i mean
it's almost unthinkable in some ways i
would say hitler coming to power um
because you could you could see that
with i mean the 1923
and right after the trial the nazis do
very very well
in the election and uh 24
uh in you know the may like but by
december you know they're already losing
a lot as the economy is getting better
and then they're going way way down
again and then it takes
the depression to really get the nazis
getting the most votes that they'll ever
get um
so i
i think it would be hard to imagine that
myself um
and what was the second question again
about that
anti-semitism in germany as opposed to
russia eastern europe and france in the
19th century and pre-hitler
i i would
it would be a guest when i go into the
late 19th century uh i'd be going back
to some of our lectures
that we did you know with you know
austria france and germany and
but
that i didn't really look into a lot of
that that early for the trial i tried to
spend five years pretty much on 1924 and
i felt like
um so i have great
respect for somebody who will take on a
whole life because this is all in one
year
and so i can go looking back to the
early you know the late
19th century
i'd have to think about it
i don't know off the top of my head
i have a guess of what like the
traditional answer but i don't really
know myself enough to say if i would say
that it's how much worse it is
um say germany and austria i mean france
and austria
i mean austria had the national
socialists well before the germans um
and
a lot of the germans were looking uh
elsewhere a lot of the nazi party
members weren't even german
too
hitler austria
hess born out in
egypt uh putzy hunched eight lot you
know in america for a long time you know
goering's wife i mean a lot of the main
people we think of rosenberg came from
the baltics a lot of them were coming in
children to richter another baltic the
guy who's marching armed arm with hitler
so a lot of the
main nazis at this time
had international
um
roots and i think that
like with munich being such a cultural
center i mean it's
my hesitation my
i would guess germany is um
far behind a lot of these places
uh especially like in the east in
austria and france but again this i'd
have to look i'd rather look and
research a little better before i said
that probably my hunch so i think you're
right about that
um so you know how in liberal
democracies we have the problem of what
do we do with extremists that don't
directly engage in violence like they
took the brits years to nail on jump
chowdery did hitler at this point
directly
engage in acts of violence and if he did
why didn't they throw the book at him
yes he did he did engage in violence in
fact he used violence he encouraged like
the storm
to go out and and brawl
because uh you know
the
first people sign up for the
stormtroopers he said are the people
that they beat up that's what he said
that was he thought i mean i don't know
how accurate that was that was always
his claim he would always say go out
we'll pick fights and people beat up
we'll be the first ones to show up and
join us next time
um and he would tell people uh you know
we're gonna go in and um
we don't walk you know don't come out
you know if you you go in to fight and
you don't come out unless they're
carrying you out
because he wanted to win the streets
and that was one way to win the streets
is through an intimidation and they're
already doing this in fact that's
one of the things about the trial when
they have um
so much security they're afraid the
stormtroopers are going to do this again
and try to spring everybody out
and um
you know have another push
so yeah he's definitely using violence
um
and that's what got him in trouble like
he was on parole at the putch
for attacking a rival speaker in 1922 in
the beer hall
he attacked the guy and uh
and he thought that was great publicity
yeah
because
even if
even if they're
praising us if they're critiquing us
they're writing about us
and that's getting us known
you tell people so
we have time for two more questions
yes
um
there were my understanding was that
there was a the national government in
germany was a moderate socialist
government and
did that have did the relationship
between the central government and the
government in munich have any effect on
how strong this was prosecuted
yes uh because that's there's a there's
a big dispute
because the trial should never have been
never been in munich
the people's court was actually we were
going to a lot of problems with the
trial it wasn't illegal
i mean once the weimar constitution was
established
these sorts of provincial
judicial organs like the people's court
was in munich
should not exist anymore and so they're
keeping it going and they're having you
can read uh some of the letters and
correspondence because uh
the the trial should have taken place in
leipzig there's a special court have
been created for all these uh traitors
that have been against the republic and
the trial should have taken place there
but it's in munich you know it's like i
mean basically a lot of people try to
figure why is it in munich
the court should it should even be in
this court it definitely shouldn't be in
munich
and it seems like there's a
it looks like there's a compromise you
can look at the you can watch like
reading some of the cabinet
meeting minutes and they're sending
these people back and forth just as
they're also doing when they're trying
to kick out hitler and try to get him to
austria at one point austria accepts him
during the trial okay we'll take him
back and by the time we get around to it
austria refuses to take him you see this
also with berlin and bavaria this huge
rivalry between berlin
and bavaria and in fact when the beer
hall puts takes place uh gustavo carr
who's speaking
it really seems
that when hitler barges into this to the
beer hall
he's upsetting their plans
to go against berlin
so that's kind of uh
so they're they're kind of upset like
that and they kind of go along it's all
you can follow it all in the book but it
really plays into this rivalry between
uh berlin and bavaria
that
that really complicates the trial
because
um it's kind of illegal
i just want to congratulate you david on
the book my name is peter range i wrote
a book a year and a half ago
around the same topic not concentrating
only on the trial this is now the
definitive book on this topic folks i've
read most of it and most important i've
read the notes on sources the 12 pages
of notes on sources in great detail
david's research is phenomenal
it's a prodigious piece of work
you know i was out of breath just
reading the notes on sources and now i
understand you spent five years on it i
spent about a year and a half
uh this is a fabulous book too
thank you very much but as he points out
this is the first book in english ever
written on the trial he couldn't believe
it when he found that out guess what
there's never been a regular full-size
book written in german on this trial so
this is the book now in english german
or any other language and
as i said i've read most of it it's
fascinating it takes you through day by
day through the trial and the period in
prison and all the rest so
congratulations oh thank you
thank you
that's it
well i really appreciate those very very
good questions fabulous books thank you
thank you can i can i say one thing this
is not a question for the remark yeah
correct okay
but i've i have a comment
no not a question
you know when you ask germans germans
today how many people lived how many
jews lived in germany before the war
you know what the answer is like 20
percent
and the truth is less than one percent
less than one percent and it's less than
one percent are responsible half of all
nobel prizes
in germany
and there's a paper by my colleagues
about 10 years ago
that the reason that the number of nobel
prizes in germany went down because
they're not jews there are very few
that's a comment that's all
thank you
thank you thank you
i really appreciate everybody
[Applause]
uh if you want to buy the books to be
signed we are selling them at the
registers
american history tv on c-span 3
exploring the people and events that
tell the american story every weekend